with soma frictional games is leaving
behind the world of amnesia and
venturing into a new setting and new
thematic territory this horror sci fi
game delves into fuse of consciousness
and instead of assaulting you with a
barrage of jump-scares soma goes for a
slow build up trying to get inside your
head you play as Simon a man who has
found himself in an abandoned science
facility Thomas grip of frictional games
says that the environments should be a
narrative playground filled with clues
that help you better understand the
game's world and piece together the
story of what's happened in these places
I love environmental storytelling so
when I played a section of the game
recently I wanted to examine every sign
and every schematic but the game is also
designed to pull in players who don't
want to investigate every little detail
players who prefer to just charge
through the game without reading
anything should still get the main gist
of the story that story remains shrouded
in mystery but a few details emerge from
my time with the game something strange
has happened with the robots in the
science facility I explored somehow it
seemed that the consciousnesses of
humans were becoming imprisoned in the
metal bodies of automatons and although
I initially thought the game might be
set in space or on a distant alien world
it actually takes place below the
surface of one of Earth's own oceans it
was as I made my way across the ocean
floor that soma started to scare me
there were noises that sounded like
distant screams and I wasn't sure if my
imagination was making more of the
muffled ocean sounds than was actually
there later making my way through the
flooded wreckage of the lambda station I
encountered the qianxi a mysterious
ghostly threat who you must hide or run
from the section of soma that I played
really was a slow build letting the
atmosphere and the sounds create a sense
of psychological fear rather than
relying on gore or jump scares I admit
I'm scared to return to somas unsettling
world but I also looked forward to
spending more time in its environments
looking at all the little details that
would help me piece together its
narrative soma is aiming for a release
on PC and ps4 in early 2015